how's it goin browse it is me my voice
is completely ruined
ah so I thought if there's ever gonna be
a perfect time for me to do an update
blog it is now because it's gonna be
chill it's just gonna be a nice little
sit-down and I honestly I am way overdue
to make one of these obviously I don't
know if you noticed this but the channel
has undergone some changes lately anyone
picked up on it but not just that but I
personally have undergone some changes
lately as well and I haven't really
addressed any of it in a video because
I've been too busy playing Minecraft so
I thought now would be the perfect time
minecraft minecraft has completely taken
over and I gotta say I absolutely love
it and it's just been so fun there's
just been so much positivity with the
channel and all the content and people
just wanting more videos and feeling
like oh I was such a good episode I
really enjoyed that that for me has been
so fun to follow and to hear from you
guys you know when you make youtube
videos or at least gaming videos and and
frequently at that sometimes you hit
certain things that maybe get really
popular but maybe you don't enjoy making
it yourself or maybe some things that
you really enjoy recording doesn't get
very popular for whatever reason or
maybe people don't like yet because it
doesn't translate as well too into video
format so it's almost like you have
these different you have these things
that you want to hit as a youtuber but
and sometimes you hit one or two of them
but with Minecraft it's just been
everything this has been all positive
but the channel is getting more abuse
than has ever gone everyone seemed
really happy and positive about it
I absolutely loved recording it and ad
revenue is absolutely fantastic like it
could not be better I know some people
are saying oh he's only playing
minecraft you guys see now he's getting
ads
no I would have done it anyway but it is
epic I'm not gonna lie I feel like I'm
finally earning what people think I'm
making out of YouTube videos merch is
still the best way to support the
channel thank you okay
it is funny looking back as well because
I did a podcast with cold ones like a
month ago or before minecraft took off
and we were talking about like oh what's
the next thing gonna be like wonder well
the next is gonna be yes I think people
are getting tired of those type of
videos yeah well it's hard to say
because no one wants to be the guy that
makes the everyone wants to be the
[ __ ] follower of that let's just wait
you should do what everyone else does
YouTube resolve is changing so quickly
it's pretty crazy but whenever my
channel gets like a second wind like
this for the hundredth time at this
point it feels like I'm always so
grateful it just feels amazing and
honestly like I can't believe I'm I
think I'm this year is my tenth year as
a youtuber uploading every single day
and to still be on top of what I do is
just unbelievable especially looking
back at other youtubers at the time you
know the longevity of youtubers was so
short
I always thought like oh I could
probably do it for like another year and
then people won't care so there's still
be able to make videos that I feel
really good about and then our audience
really like as well it's pretty crazy
when I started off youtube I made videos
for like a whole year and no one really
watched it I'm sure you've seen some of
my older videos youtube like to
recommend them very specifically like my
hundred subs special or whatever and
yeah today we're gonna celebrate because
I got 100 subscribers oh my
but once I started playing amnesia which
was the thing that really took off for
my channel because I played this horror
game and I was giving these little
objects in the game names never Stefano
there was barrels which was even I mean
it's the same cause as I'm doing now
that I think about it but it was like a
very endearing time for my memory and my
heart at that time and you know that's
what I really fell in love with YouTube
doing that stuff and that's when I
decided I'm gonna pursue being a
youtuber because this is amazing and
then you know it kind of went down a lot
after a while after a few years people
kind of got bored of scary games and so
did I so that was a very stressful
period when you're trying to transition
into something else as a youtuber so to
be here again doing the same thing like
with Minecraft having that moment that I
had when I started off I never thought I
would relive that ever I never thought I
would experience that again and I'm so
happy that I get to do that with mine
crime and I feel like such a douche bag
or like peeing on this game would be
like no it's too popular I don't want to
play it and then Here I am like oh it's
actually good but also looking back I
feel like now was the perfect time for
me to play it you know it's not just
about the game it's also the timing I
think at least it feels like I've come
to a full circle with a channel now
coming back to gaming this way and
looking back you know it's been a rocky
road and I think that's almost why a lot
of people appreciate the channel at this
point and I appreciate everyone sticking
through with me throughout like all the
controversies and and all that stuff and
obviously looking back now I kind of
feel like
very stupid about it and how a lot of it
just wasn't worth it so basically I'm
sorry for all the bad things I've done I
just want to play minecraft please I
guess I just realized it's like this is
why I started making videos it's what I
enjoy doing obviously I'm not gonna be
able to be minecraft forever there's
always gonna be the next thing or
whatever but then again if I stop
playing minecraft then my pit
sven is gonna be alone and I can't let
that happen
another big change in for the channel
has been Brad who's been editing for for
those who don't know I used to have two
editors Brad and Syme so I was still
working with me but Brad left to do his
own thing Brad and I have been working
together for five years and we made a
lot of really amazing videos that I'm
really really proud of
you're wearing a life jacket beats Mouse
264 should I be wearing a life jacket oh
absolutely
ever man
get it and make it
I see swallowed him so now it's just me
and and sighs and I was looking for a
new editor right away but in the
meanwhile I was editing my own Minecraft
episodes and for those of you don't know
for five for the first five years of me
making videos I was editing every single
day and as tedious that can be n s
tedious and time-consuming that can be
it's also something I've missed for a
while and I realized while editing the
Minecraft videos that I actually really
enjoy editing those and I can tell that
you guys enjoy it as well because
instead of just trying to record the
video and just get it up because
tomorrow we have another video so it
doesn't matter you know that's kind of
the attitude we had to keep with the
frequency of the uploads on this channel
and considering most of the time it's
two people involved to get the video
down instead when when I get to edit it
I can sort of shape it in a way that
makes more sense than I can really make
it exactly how I want it and I can put
that little extra effort in which a lot
of times I've seen is unnecessary but
it's been really fun to do that and
there's a lot of Minecraft episodes now
that I always sounds crunchy but I
generally feel very proud of like the
the whether episode and you get all that
stupid stuff I love that I think it's so
fun to make that stuff and I'm very very
happy with that it's been a while since
I've been able to say like oh I feel
really proud of this video so that feels
really good as well you know they said
what I said I feel like I'm naturally
coming back to where I started with this
channel and I enjoy it
I really did another thing is that I'm
getting married soon right yeah I can't
wait to be your husband I'm very excited
but it's also been a lot of work and
then to also edit my own videos it's
been hard to keep up so there's no I'm
trying my best with the time that I have
each day for anyone that's a youtuber
that you know it's a grind and for a lot
of other businesses whenever you start
something and
reach a level of success you can kind of
like slow down a bit and let other
people take over the work but to still
have me here to like doing all that it's
kind of crazy if you think about it but
at the same time this is what I enjoy
doing this is what I want to do so I'm
actually just happy about it I think
it's fun the final thing I wanted to
address now is that you know I'm getting
married
brides left get hitting a hundred
million subscribers did use an insane
number it's the dumbest number I ever
heard but I still have believe it
like before YouTube I was that weird kid
with no friends and then all the sudden
there's so many people that enjoy what I
do it's pretty insane to me I like I
still can't wrap my head around it
honestly thank you everyone for
subscribing whether your been here since
the beginning or on and off or for a
little while I really appreciate
everyone immune I there's been a lot of
speculation that I'm gonna quit the
channel because first of all these
pieces kind of falling together I still
really enjoy YouTube and I'd have no
plans of quitting I do think it would be
good for me to take a break at some
point just to feel what it's like to
have a break okay I don't take breaks I
just keep going and going and going
because I'm so in the routine of making
videos but it would be nice to just not
have YouTube in my brain for the first
time in ten years I'll probably do that
at some point in the future at least but
I just wanted to address the whole he's
gonna quit thing other than that I just
want to say I'm really happy um you guys
seem happy as well and that just feels
really good and I think that's the
bottom line is that I just really enjoy
making uplifting content and it was good
to do that so thank you everyone for
watching this has been the update vlog
hope you enjoyed
check out March
you don't have to like honestly but it
would be epic I'll see you guys in
tomorrow's video bye bye